you posted this awesome video on your
instagram of a woman
who was being interviewed in the 19th
late 1920s maybe yes yeah
yeah
and she's close to 100 years old
so she's lived through the civil war
through world war one she was at the
time living through the early days of
the great depression
so i was just looking back you know what
have we as a human civilization in
recent times survived especially in the
united states
you're talking about the two world wars
in the 20th century the great depression
the spanish food the pandemic at the
beginning of the 20th century yeah uh
what do we do in the united states 9 11.
if you think of what are the traumatic
events that shook our world
it's 911
it made us rethink our place in the
world
um
the pandemic pandemic is a huge one it's
i mean one of the bigger ones because it
also accelerated and exacerbated our
anxiety which people have a certain
level of anxiety already especially
sedentary people they have a very high
level of anxiety already because i don't
think they're they're giving their body
what it
what it needs
i don't think they're you know your body
has certain requirements in terms of
movement and when you deny your body
those requirements i think there's like
a general level of anxiety that exists
in almost everyone and then you have
people obviously that have mental health
issues and that also exacerbates the
anxiety the lockdown exacerbated the
anxiety losing loved ones to the
pandemic exacerbated anxiety and then
there was the the division that the
different schools of thought the people
that were never going to get vaccinated
no matter what i ain't trusting it
people who thought there was microchips
in there people that thought that you
know fauci's the demon and there's there
was a lot
and there's also like political
leanings the right-wing people tended to
not want to be vaccinated whereas the
left-wing people
for whatever reason all of a sudden
they're trusting pharmaceutical
companies
like explicitly it was weird
it's a it was a weird time and i think
uh
over time as it's gonna as it gets
analyzed and we we break it down it's
going to be one of the weirder moments
for shaping human culture and
unfortunately for throwing gasoline on
this already
burning fire of
you
know of
conflict between
the various factions of of thought in
this country it's just a
it's already a weird time you know
post-trump
you